WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
HEARING ON AUGUST THIRTY FIRST-
LET ME GO THROUGH SOME OF. OUR
SPECIAL RULES IN THIS KIND OF
AN ERA DO THEY CONTINUES TO
HEAD HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL JUST
MISSING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT TH CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE ARE
ALSO APPLYING THAT MASS BE
WARNED AND FISCAL DISCIPLINE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR ANY VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU NOT
HAVE AMASSED WE CAN AVOID ONE
FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM IF ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL. PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AT
THE- GIVEN TIME- ON THE
PROPERTY BILL. AND I'LL ASK YOU
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE OF
AT THAT TIME. I WOULD ASK THAT
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
FISCAL DISCIPLINE IN THE
CAPITOL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. FOR DIALING WITNESSES
YOU WILL BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE. THROUGH
WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY
ON A BILL. THE CALLING ON THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER. ON
THE ASSEMBLY LABOUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. YOU'RE CALLING AND
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL. YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERABLE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. FOR CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCASTS ON YOUR
SMART DEVICES. TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. YOU HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS THE MODERATE PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
ONE. THEN MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH. THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE- ALL SAY THE WEBSITE
SLOWLY IT'S W. W. W. DOT. A. L.
B. R. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA. DOT
GOV. W. W. W. DOT A. L. B. E.
R. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT G.
O. V. SO FEEL FREE TO SEND IN
ANY. POSITIONS OR ANYTHING LIKE
TO SEND INAT THAT WEBSITE FOR
ANY OF THE MATTERS BEFORE US
THIS EVENING. WE MANY THE LIMIT
HOW LONG THE PHONE LINES ARE
OPEN FOR EACH BILL AS YOU'RE ON
A- TIGHT HEARING SCHEDULE HERE
IN OUR LAST EVENING IN SESSION-
AND WE DO THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
PET FOR YOUR PATIENCE. OF WE
HAVE WITH US IN THE ROOM- MORE
ON THIS- THE PART OF MY STAFF
HERE CHIEF CONSULTANT MAKE
ELAINE WHO WILL. BE HELPING TO
TAKE ROLE. IN AT THIS TIME- I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK IF MAKING. IF
YOU CAN TAKE ORDER STATUS
QUORUM PLEASE. KALRA. FLORIDA
HERE CARILLO YEAH DEEP.
CONVULSE JONES SAWYER THERE.
RIVAS. PRESIDENT WELCOME SALAS
RIGHT. OKAY SO WE HAVE A QUORUM.
ONE CERTAIN OKAY SO- SO THE
FIRST BILL WE HAVE UP IS A. B.
SIX EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RADIUS AND FOR
WITNESSES THIS EVENING HELLO
ASK EACH SIDE TO KEEP THE TOTAL
TESTIMONY TO FOUR MINUTES YOU
CAN SPLIT IT UP. MUGS WITNESSES
ANYWAY YOU SO CHOOSE AND YOU DO
NOT HAVE TO USE ALL THE TIME IF
YOU DON'T NEED ALL THE TIME
THAT'S FOR ALL THE WITNESSES
TO. TESTIFY IN AFTER A
MYSTERIOUS PRESS PRESENTS
TESTIFYING SUPPORT YOU HAVE
GIVEN BIGELOW YES W. SURPLUS
COVER LABOR. FEDERATION AND SO
LET ME START BY. ASKING SUMMARY
IS TO BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. TODAY I
PRESENT TO YOU AB SIXTY FIVE
WHICH IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
AIMED AT PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITIES AND LOWERING
EXPOSURE TO COPE WITH NINETEEN
SPECIFICALLY EXPOSURES IN THE
WORKPLACE. CURRENTLY THERE IS
NO LAW THAT MANDATES THAT
EMPLOYERS NOTIFYING WORKERS OF
POTENTIAL COVERT NINETEEN
EXPOSURE IN THE WORKPLACE. IT
IS CLEAR THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS GONE ABOVE AND BEYOND TO
ENSURE OUR EMPLOYEES AND
MEMBERS HERE IN THE CAPITAL ARE
SAFE AND PROTECTED.
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ALL EMPLOYEES
IN THE STATE HAVE THAT LUXURY
OR ACCOMMODATION. EVERY DAY OUR
CENTRAL WORKERS ARE RISKING
THEIR LIVES AND THE LIVES OF
THEIR LOVED ONES WHENEVER THEY
GO TO WORK TO KEEP OUR STATE
FUNCTIONING WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER AS A
GOVERNING BODY TO ENSURE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS ARE PROTECTED.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THAT
EMPLOYERS REPORT FATALITIES AND
SERIOUS INCIDENTS. BUT IT IS
ONLY RECOMMENDED THAT EMPLOYERS
REPORT ON COBIT NINETEEN
INFECTIONS. THERE IS NO
COMPREHENSIVE MANDATE TO REPORT
EXPOSURES AND CASES. PUBLICLY
FOR TRACKING PURPOSES THIS BILL
CREATES SIMPLE AND CLEAR
GUIDELINES FOR WHAT EMPLOYERS
SHOULD DO WHEN HE OR SHE IS
INFORMED THAT SOMEONE AT WORK
IT HAS TESTED POSITIVE OR BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH COPD NINETEEN.
IT ALLOWS ONE BUSINESS DAY TO
NOTIFY WORKERS WHO WERE ON THE
PREMISES WITH THE PERSON WHO
HAS COVERT NINETEEN. THAT
NOTICE SHOULD TELL WORKERS WHAT
TYPE OF SICK LEAVE THEY MAY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR AND THE
DISINFECTION AND SAFETY PLAN
FOR THE WORKSITE. IF THREE
WORKERS TEST POSITIVE WITHIN
FOURTEEN DAYS WHICH IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH DEFINITION OF AN
OUTBREAK. THE EMPLOYER MUST
REPORT TO LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. THAT IS THE EXTENT
OF THE EMPLOYER OBLIGATION. TO
SIMPLE REQUIREMENTS TO LIMIT
WORKSITE SPREAD AND PREVENT
WORKERS FROM BRINGING THE VIRUS
HOME TO VULNERABLE FAMILY
MEMBERS. IN ADDITION THIS BILL
REQUIRES A STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT TO TRACK EMPLOYER
OUTBREAKS SO THAT WE CAN WORK
WITH STATE AND LOCAL ENTITIES
TO ENSURE WORKERS ARE PROTECTED
AND UNDERSTAND TRENDS OVER TIME.
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY- REMOTELY
IN SUPPORT OF OUR CAITLIN VEGA
WITH UFC W. AND SARA FLOCKS
WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND WE DO HAVE YOU HAVE
THE WITNESSES ONLINE I WANT TO
BE KEEPING TIME UP HERE AGAIN
MAXIMUM FOUR MINUTES TOTAL OF
BETWEEN THE TWO WITNESSES SO.
WE CAN GO AHEAD AND BEGIN. WITH
MISS SURVEY A- NUMBER EIGHT
THEN DATA ON BEHALF OF THE U.
S. SIXTY LEFT. OUT TO BE
COACHED FONG THAT MATCH AND WE
THINK ASSEMBLY RAY YES HER
LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS THE
LATINO CAUCUS FOR MAKING THIS
BILL A PRIORITY. AND WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN UP AND DOWN THE STATE
OUR WORK SITE CLUSTERS WORK
LARGE NUMBERS OF WORKERS HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED AT THE WORK SITE
WHERE THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
NOTIFIED OF COVERT INFECTION AT
THE WORK SITE IN MANY CASES
THEY HAVE GONE HOME TO THEIR
FAMILIES. AND THEIR FAMILIES
THANK- SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T KNOW THAT THEY HAD BEEN
EXPOSED- OUTWORK IN ADDITION WE
HAVE VERY LITTLE ABILITY TO
TRACK THESE WORKSITE OUTBREAKS
WHICH MEANS THAT WE CAN'T
DIRECT THE KINDS OF RESOURCES
THAT WE NEED WE CAN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT KIND OF SAFETY
PROTOCOLS ARE WORKING WHERE
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES SHOULD BE
TARGETED WE'RE TESTING SHOULD
BE MADE AVAILABLE. THERE IS
SIMPLY A LACK OF INFORMATION
ABOUT THE ROLE OF WORKSITE
SPREAD AND THIS HAS BEEN
CATASTROPHIC PUTS THE LATINO
COMMUNITY. BUT YOU KNOW
IMMIGRANTS ARE OVER REPRESENTED
IN INDUSTRIES LIKE AGRICULTURE
MEAT PACKING PLANTS- POULTRY
PLANTS LIKE FOSTER FARMS THAT
WE SAW OVER THE WEEKEND HAD
ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED WORKERS-
WHO HAD COATED EIGHT HAVE
ALREADY PASSED AWAY- AND- SO.
BECAUSE OF THE FAILURE TO
TRACKWORK SITES BUT OR CONTROL
IT WE HAVE SEEN THIS GROW
UNABATED WITHIN LATINO
COMMUNITY WHO NOW REPRESENT
MORE THAN 60% OF CASES IN
CALIFORNIA. THE POOL OF THIS
BILL IS VERY SIMPLE IS MINIMAL
PROTECTIONS TO REDUCE BURKE
SAID SPREAD NOTICE TO THE
WORKER THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED AND NOTICE TO PUBLIC
HEALTH WHEN THERE HAD BEEN AN
OUT. BUT THEY'RE THE ONLY
OBLIGATION ON EMPLOYERS UNDER
THE STUFF. WE HAD ENGAGE WITH
THE PLAYERS FROM THE BEGINNING-
WE DO BELIEVE THAT AS A WORKER
SAFETY CRISIS WE HAVE A GREAT
SENSE OF URGENCY AND YET WE
HAVE HAD. MANY MANY MANY
MEETINGS WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND TAKEN A SIGNIFICANT.
AMENDMENTS ON EVERY PROVISION
OF THE STILL TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT IS SIMPLE AND CLEAR
IMPLEMENTED. FOR THE PLAY AND
AT THE SAME WE REALLY FEEL LIKE
WE ARE TRYING TO LIVES HERE AND
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE THAT WORK
HAVE THE RIGHT TO GO SAFE TO
THEIR FAMILY AT THE ENDOF THE
DAY. AND SO WITH THAT WE ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU. I
MISS FOX. ONE MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS SERRA FLOCK TO THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION A
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL-
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RAY AS RELEASED
I'M BEST AT BUT THIS IS A BILL
THAT IS NOT ABOUT SHAMING ANY
EMPLOYER THIS IS A BILL ABOUT
FEEDING WORKERS LIVES AND ABOUT
PREVENTING OUTBREAKS BEFORE
THEY SPREAD IT REALLY IS SO
THAT LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
THE PUBLIC WORKERS AND STATE
POLICYMAKERS HAVE THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED SO
THEY CAN INTERVENE AT WORKSITE
BEFORE OUTBREAKS GET OUT OF
CONTROL AND I CAN BE WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH DID
IN SHUTTING DOWN FOSTER FARMS
HE COULD BE SAYING OKAY WE HAVE
THREE CASES AT THIS WORK SITE
WE'RE GONNA GET MOBILE TESTING
THERE WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY HAS THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED AND
THE HEALTHCARE THAT THEY NEED.
THIS REALLY IS THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE WAY WE CAN THINK OF
TO TAKE THE STRAPPED RESOURCES
THAT OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND CAL OSHA HAVE
AND DIRECT THEM TO THE PLACES
WHERE WE CAN BE MOST EFFECTIVE
AND SO WE THINK THAT IS A GREAT
BELL AND THE AMENDMENTS REALLY
TIGHTEN IT UP AND. WE WOULD
URGE YOUR ITEM THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IF NOT IS
THERE ANYONE THAT IS ON- THE
LINE IN SUPPORT. BUT ANYWAY
THIS ON THEIR OWN ALL RIGHT. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO.
OUR FIRST- PARTICIPANT IS ONE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING NO I THOUGHT I'M
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT I'M CALLING REMOTELY
FROM MODESTO STANISLAUS COUNTY
WHICH IS RIGHT NEXT DOOR TO
MERCED COUNTY LIVINGSTON WHERE
THE FOSTER FARMS AND KICK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. EXTROVERT
LINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU RENEE BAYARDO
WITH YEAH ARE YOU CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIVE
SIXTY YOU ARE OPEN. IT SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRISTY VALVE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF THE
DEFENDER OF THE HAVE EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES REPORT. THANK
YOU. WE WERE LINE. FIFTY SIX.
COULD YOU ARE BUT- LET YOU
SHARE MEMBERS NOT BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS
IMPORTANT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FIND SIXTY TWO YOU ARE ALL BUT.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS
BUSINESS KANILANG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION WITH YOUR OR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER KAREN
MEMBERS TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. RIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. VANDERBUR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IT. THANK
YOU. ONE OFFICER MORE
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP. ONE
SIXTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN.
CUSTOMER SERVICE IS A TRUE
THOUGH THE CALL THE STREAMING
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
LIKE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KEVIN TO DRAW THE
REPRESENTING NFIB WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE. OKAY
THANK YOU NOTED. EIGHT FIFTY
THREE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS- BUT
WE'RE ON THE HAPPY COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS
THE THING ABOUT AGRICULTURE
EDUCATION FRIENDLY- MEDINA
COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM. AFTER BY
ACTION NETWORK CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NETWORK STATE I STATE
COOL. ENOUGH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP CALLING. AT THE
PORT OF EIGHTY SIX EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU. FIVE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO ORDER TO RECORD
THE OPTICAL PHONE APP CAN
ATTORNEYS SOCIALIZATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. EXTRALITE. FIFTY SIX.
FIFTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. SHARE
MEMBERS BACKGROUND AGAIN THIS
TIME ON THE AFTER THE CONSUMER
JOURNEY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
INTO COURT. THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS CUED UP WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO GET THE INSTRUCTIONS
ONE MORE TIME SURE DO ONE MORE
TIME FOR EVERYONE'S BENEFIT. AS
A REMINDER OUT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE FIFTY SIX WHO. IT IS WHAT
THERE ARE NO WEATHER OUT
BUDGETS BUT QUEUING UP THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WELL LET'S MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION. TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION BY PHONE WE ARE
ROBERT MUTRIE WITH CALCHAMBER.
UP TO FOUR MINUTES YOU DON'T
HAVE TO GO TIME. I THANK THE
CHAIRMAN OF. I'LL TRY THAT IT
YOU FEEL FREE TO ADD ON A YEAH
ANYWAY HAVE A PERFORMANCE. IN
RECORD WITH YOUR FOR CALCHAMBER
OPPOSED TO AB SIXTY FIVE AND I
WOULD SAY I THINK ON BEHALF OF
A BROAD COALITION WE WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENT THAT. ARE COST
EFFECTIVE ACROSS ALL TYPES OF
PLAYERS ACROSS ALL INDUSTRIES
REGIONS AND SIZES IN THE STATE
BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE AND THE
PRESS THAT COALITION I THINK
IT'S AN EXAMPLE OF THE FACT
THAT ARE A BIT RATHER
DEMONSTRATIVE FACT THAT THE
TEXT OF THE BILL. JEFF HAD HUGE
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES- I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE OFFICE OFFICE FOR
LINKING GATE AND PROP THAT AT
AS WE STATED PREVIOUSLY BUT WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL STILL
CONTAINS ALL THE TECHNICAL
ISSUES AND SO WE REMAIN.
OPPOSED TO BE CLEAR. WE NOT
YEARS DOWN PAY THE TO COOK
NINETEEN WE'RE NOT OF. TO
PROVIDE NOTICE. TO EMPLOYEES
THE EVENT EXPOSURE IF THAT WAS
ALL THE BILL DID THEN DID WE DO
HAVE A DIFFERENT DISCUSSION-
BUT I'LL GIVE YOU TWO EXAMPLES
THAT THE TEXTUAL ISSUES THAT
REMAIN IN THE- BILL TO THE DAY.
AND NEED TO BE FIXED SO THAT
IT'S WORKABLE- FIRST THE BILL
IS VAGUE STILL AT THE DESPITE
THE MULTIPLE ROUNDS EVENT. AT
UKHRUL MUST RECEIVE NOTICE AND
WHAT NOTED THEY MUST. YOUR
SEATS. AN EXAMPLE THE BILL I
PROVIDE FOR THREE SET OF DOC HE-
TO AVOID- I NOTICED THE CLOSURE
A SET OF LABOR DOCUMENT AND
THEN ALSO THAT A CLEANING PAUL.
I THINK THIS IS AN ERROR BUT
PRESENT THE BILL ACTUALLY THE
DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS FOR WHO
GETS EACH OF THOSE DOCUMENTS.
AND SOME OF THE DIFFERENT
DEFINITIONS ARE COMPLETELY
UNDEFINED SO ONE OF THE THAT
THE DOCUMENT GOES TO ANYONE WHO
WAS EXPOSED. BUT THE BILL
DOESN'T DEFINE WHO WAS EXPOSED
ANOTHER THAT GOES TO THE GROUP
ON THE WORK THAT AT THE TIME
WHICH MAKES SENSE. THE THIRD
THAT WILL BE SENT OUT A
COMPANYWIDE WITHIN TWENTY
WITHIN ONE BUSINESS DAY
WHATEVER THAT MAY EXPOSURE I
GET I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
OFFICE INTENT. BUT I THINK THAT
WILL CLEAR TEXTUAL ERRORS THAT
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HERE I TRY TO COMPLY WITH.
WORLD SPACE HELLO SHE CANNOT.
BUT I KNOW THE OFFICE. SIX
INTEREST IN CLEANUP LANGUAGE
NOW YEAR. BUT I'D BE REMISS IF
I DIDN'T FLAG THE ISSUE THAT WE
BREAK THE LAW. A SECOND ISSUE
IS THAT THE BILL HAS A LONG
STANDING ISSUE WITH THE
DEFINITION OF A POSITIVE CASE
DOCTOR PAN RATE THIS ISSUE WITH
THAT LABOR THE BILL QUICKLY
PROVIDE THAT- LAB CONFIRMED
CASES THE CODE NINETEEN WILL
TRIGGER NOTICE BUT AS DR PANDA
BEAR LAB CONFIRMED CASES CAN BE
CHAU EITHER ACTIVE VIRUS OR
ANTIBODY REQUIRED SECTION AND
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON ACTIVE
BUYERS THIS BILL DOESN'T
DIFFERENTIATE. THE ONE THING
OFF LIKE BRIEFLY THEN I'LL BE
DONE IT IS THE BILL DOES CREATE
A PUBLICATION REQUIREMENT TO
THE PUBLIC- AND THERE WAS
DISCUSSION ABOUT SHARING
MENTION BUT LIKE TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT WHY WE THINK THAT
PUBLICATION AGREEMENT THAT
WOULD HELP THE BATTLE REPORT TO
T. P. H. THEY'LL TAKE THEM HOW
THE PRODUCT THAT THEY WILL BE
POSTED THAT THE DATA COMES OUT
A WEEK TO TWO WEEKS LATER ON
THEIR WEBSITE FOR SPECIFIC
WORKS THAT- THAT DATA BY THE
TIME IT IS POSTED THE TICKET
POLICE WILL BE OUT OF. OUR THE
WORKSITE THE WORK THAT WILL
HAVE BEEN CLEAN AT THE DANGER
THERE NOW LIKE IT MEDICALLY
CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS THE FOSTER
FARMS YOU'VE ALL HEARD ABOUT
THAT WE CERTAIN CASES WITH HUGE
PROBLEMS FOR MOST EMPLOYERS BY
THE TALENT THAT IT POSTED IT
WILL HAVE BEEN DEALT BUT WHAT
WILL HAPPEN IS A PARTICULAR
GROUP OR SMALLER BUSINESSES
RESTAURANTS AND OTHERS THAT
HAVE TO WORK WITH CUSTOMERS.
THERE WILL BE HANGING
INFORMATION ONLINE ABOUT PRIOR
CASES WHICH WILL PROFESSOR IS
THE ULTIMATE NO ONE COMING IN
UNDERSTANDABLY THAT WILL KILL
THE BUSINESSES OF ENTERPRISE
RESTAURANT POLITICS REALLY
STRUGGLE TO FILL AYE RIGHT NOW
THAT'S SOMETHING. THAT THE HUGE
CONCERN TO US. GIVE A SHORT
THAT WE ARE OPPOSED TO COURT
THE BILL WE REALLY THINK THAT
IT MOVED TO. THAT YEAR THERE.
CONCERN ALL TAX. INQUIRED AND A
COUPLE POLICIES. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE- THE- HOPE WE BUTTON
FOR ME. THOSE FINE YOU
PRITCHARD. OKAY IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM AND UP. RIGHT IF
NOT IF WE CAN GO OVER TO THE-
THE PHONE LINE. SHOW YOUR
OPPOSITION ON THE FRONT LINES
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT FIRST WE
WERE LYING THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THAT YOU CARED
ABOUT ROBINSON WERE SHORTER AND
TO SHELTER BLANK ON BEHALF OF
THE SPECIALLY EQUIPPED BARTLETT
SUFFICIENT ENOUGH- WE REPRESENT
TWO THOUSAND MEMBER COMPANIES
IN CALIFORNIA. THE REQUESTED BY
THE CHAMBER WE ARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. THANKS SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS NICOLE
RICE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION IF
YOU ALLOWING MISTER CHAIR I DO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THEIR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US
TO MAKE THE BILL MORE WORKABLE-
AND WE DEFINITELY THANK THEM
FOR THAT UNFORTUNATELY AS MR
MOULTRIE HAS POINTED OUT THERE
STILL REMAINS SOME TECHNICAL AS
WELL AS INSPECTED IT ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE. ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT AND SO UNFORTUNATELY AT
THE TIME WE ARE FELT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIVE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JIM LIGHTS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AIRPORTS COUNCIL UNFORTUNATELY
WE TO REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DESPITE SEVENTY FOUR YOU ARE
ALL BUT- IF THE THIRTY YEARS OF
THE CALIFORNIA COULD PREDICT
PROTECTED LAND MY COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF THE CHAMBER AND THE
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND AGAIN THANK YOU
THANK THE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR
HARD WORK IS NEEDED TO GO A
LITTLE FURTHER TO MAKE THE BILL
A BIT MORE WORKABLE FOR OUR
MEMBERS. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FORTY
TWO. GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS NOT APPLY ON BEHALF OF
THE FAMILY WINEMAKERS THE
CALIFORNIA AND THE WESTERN CAR
WASH ASSOCIATION BOTH IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BY TWENTY NINE
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD EVENING TURN
MEMBERS MCCARTY AT NONDESCRIPT
SPENDING OF GAS AND ELECTRIC
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS
COMPANY OFTEN RESPECT BOB
VISION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FIVE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CLAPPING DOWN OFTEN ON
BEHALF OF UNITED AIRLINES AND
THEIR ASSOCIATION- LINE FOR
AMERICA OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK
YOU. MY FIFTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BARNO
AND HE DID NOT HAVE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET NEUTRAL
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION CONGENERS AND
BURDEN SAYS EACH AND WESTERN
AND PRACTICES THAT THAT THE H.
AND OTHER ARAB ORGANIZATION-
AGAIN. THANK FOR THE OCTOBER
WORK BUT FOR THE REASONS THE
CHAMBER STATED AND PACIFIC LEE
THE PUBLICATION PIECE WE REMAIN.
OPPOSED THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY
OUT FIFTY ARE EXCUSE ME THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
EVENING MR MEMBERS OF THE
JENNIFER SNYDER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES UNFORTUNATELY
WE STILL REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
BILL. AND I'M HOPING SHE
KNEELING TO WORK ON THAT-
THINGS WE CAN DO IN THE FUTURE
WITH CLEAN UP LEGISLATION THAT
IMPORTANT PERSONAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LIVE CONSERVE-
DOESN'T NAME ORGANIZATIONAL
POSITION LEAVE WILL ASSUME
YOU'RE ALL GOING TO GET YOU TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND TRY TO
MAKE IT BETTER BUT- JUST IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME TO GET THE.
NAME OF THE ORGANIZATION
POSITION PLEASE THANK YOU.
MOVING ON TO ONE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SEVEN A NUMBER THAT
IS FIVE. ARE ALREADY OPPOSITION
TO THE- FIVE. BUT OKAY. THANK
YOU. MOREOVER LINE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER MEMBERS
JOHN LINGER ON THE UP
CALIFORNIA FUEL INCONVENIENT
THE LINE CALLS ON OUR STREETS.
THANK YOU. FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOU ARE OPEN. BOB NAYLOR
REPRESENTING THE SIX BEDS
LINCOLN ASSOCIATION OF TWO
THOUSAND PLUS ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITIES WE UNFORTUNATELY
REMAIN OPPOSED THANK YOU BYE.
ONE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IN BREAKING WILL BE A PHYSICIAN
A CALIFORNIA HEALTH RESTRICT
SOMEONE PERSONALLY PUT IT
PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FIVE FIFTY ONE YOU
ARE ALL BUT- GIVENS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OBSTACLE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. BUILDING ALONG TO
LINE THIRTY THREE AND PER
ANYBODY ELSE IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SHOW YOUR OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. EIGHT THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER MATTHEW
OUTLOOK WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY
SIX. GOOD EVENING MISTER KAREN
MEMBERS TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
ALSO RESPECTFULLY REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTS QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MOST. WITH
THE MOST A SECOND. THANK YOU
HAVE SUPPORT YES IS RIGHT SURE.
THANK YOU A CHAIR CREATE THAT
NEVER BRING IN THIS- I DO RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS AND I
WASN'T ACTUALLY. REALLY SURE
THAT THIS WAS GOING DIRECTLY AT
FOSTER FARMS WHICH IS ONE OF
THE BEST. AND LARGEST EMPLOYERS
M. IN MY DISTRICT ND IT'S
ACTUALLY VERY SAD THAT THIS
OUTBREAK HAS HAPPENED TO THEM.
BUT THIS IS A BUSINESS THAT HAS
DONE. PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING
THEY'VE BEEN ASKED TO DO AND
HAS FAR EXCEEDED WHAT THE STATE
HAS MANDATED. SO I WOULD JUST
ARGUE. THAT THIS IS A FAILURE.
OF MERCED COUNTY PAHO AND THEIR
INABILITY TO GET THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE BUSINESSES NEED TO DO
THE TESTING THAT IS REQUIRED
FOR FACILITIES THAT ARE THIS
LARGE AND I DON'T KNOW THE
EXACT NUMBER AND I WAS TRYING
TO GET THOSE NUMBERS BEFORE I
SPOKE WITH A JUST MOVED A
LITTLE BIT QUICKER ON HOW MANY
TESTS THAT THEY HAD DONE. PRIOR
TO THIS OUTBREAK AND SO IT IS
FRUSTRATING THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT IRRITATING BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THE NEED AND NONE OF
US WANT OUTBREAKS ESPECIALLY IN
LARGE BUSINESSES BECAUSE THESE
ARE GENERATIONAL JOBS WE HAVE
MULTIPLE GENERATIONS OF THE
SAME FAMILY WORKING AT THIS
PARTICULAR TIME FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESS AND THEY'RE
INCREDIBLY- WELL PAID AND IT'S
WHY THEY KEEP COMING BACK TO
WORK THERE AND SO IT IS VERY
VERY UNFORTUNATE BUT I AM
ACTUALLY. KIND OF FOLLOWING
THIS LAST FEW WEEKS AND HOUSES
DEVELOPED. WE ARE THE STATE AND
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL EXPRESSLY
WITH THE MANDATE SO WE'RE
PUTTING ON OUR BUSINESSES LAST
WEEK WE HAVE AN OUTBREAK IN THE
SENATE RIGHT BUT IT WAS A LIAR
OUR SENATE COLLEAGUES ARE
QUARANTINED IN THEIR APARTMENTS
RIGHT NOW I ROOM WITH ONE. I
TRY TO GET TESTED. AND I WAS
TOLD I DIDN'T HAVE TO. OKAY SO
THIS IS A HUGE FRUSTRATION THAT
WE HAVE BECAUSE THERE'S NO
CONSISTENCY AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVELS WE HAVE NO. WE
JUST NO CONSISTENCY SO IT IS
INCREDIBLY FRESH AND WE HOLD
OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITY TO A
STANDARD. BUT WE DON'T REALLY
TAKE IT TO HEART AND SO I WOULD
JUST WANT TO PUT OUT THERE THAT
I AM. I'M UPSET THAT THIS
HAPPENED TO ONE OF THE BEST
BUSINESSES THAT WE HAVE. IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND CERTAINLY.
THE LARGEST EMPLOYER IN OUR
REGION SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SUMMER GONZALEZ I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT THIS BILL WAS IN THE
WORKS BEFORE UNFORTUNATELY WHAT
WE FOUND OUT FOSTER FARMS AND
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT AND I
RESPECTED BUSINESS. AT A
UNIONIZED WILL PAIN BUSINESS IN
YOUR DISTRICT BUT THIS IS WHAT
WE NOW THERE WERE STATE
REGULATORS THERE IN JUNE THEY
GAVE THEM- SPECIFIC
INSTRUCTIONS ON THINGS THAT
COULDBE DONE THOSE WERE
IGNORED. EIGHT PEOPLE ARE DEAD
DEAD. BECAUSE OF THAT. I I'M
SORRY. IT'S NOT AN
INCONVENIENCE WHEN THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE DYING OUR FROM OUR
COMMUNITY TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
WHETHER IT'S A PROCESSING
FACILITY OR WHETHER IT'S A
FAMILY FARM OR WHETHER IT'S A
LARGE INDUSTRIAL FARM WE ARE
LOSING OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS
BECAUSE RULES ARE NOT FOLLOWED.
THEY WERE TOLD TO SHUT DOWN BY
COUNTY HEALTH AND THEY DID NOT
DO SO FOR TWO DAYS BECAUSE THEY
NEEDED TO GET THE HARVEST OUT
WOULD HARVEST IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN THE LIVES OF WORKERS THAT
WE DON'T SEE OR HEAR. SOMETHING
IS WRONG THIS WAS NOT ABOUT
FOSTER FARMS BUT THIS IS ABOUT
EVERY EMPLOYER WHO IS TAKING
THE RISK ON BEHALF OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES AS THEY KNOW THERE'S
A BREAKOUT. AND THEY REFUSED TO
TELL OTHER WORKERS THAT THERE'S
AN OUTBREAK IN THEIR FACILITY
BEING KNOW IT EXISTS THEY
REFUSE TO TELL THEM. THEY DO
NOT TELL THEM THE RIGHTS WERE
WORKING WITH PEOPLE WHO DON'T
EVEN REALIZE THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO STAY HOME. WHO ARE
BATTLING BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
ACCESS ANY KIND OF HELP OUTSIDE
OF THE FACILITY BECAUSE MANY
TIMES UNDOCUMENTED. THAT IS THE
TRUTH IT IS AN UNCOMFORTABLE
TRUTH BUT IT HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
LATINO COCKETT THE LATINO
COMMUNITY AND THAT'S WHY IT'S A
PRIORITY BILL. AND I GET IT.
IT'S DISCOURAGING BECAUSE
TESTING SHOULD BE BETTER IN THE
STATE SHOULD HAVE. A BETTER
HANDED THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
THAT AS WELL BUT THE
pTO ONE TELL OTHER EMPLOYEES
WHEN THERE'S AN OUTBREAK TO
TELL THEM OF THE RIGHT TO BE
ABLE TO STAY HOME IF THEY'RE
SICK. TELL THEM OF THE RIGHTS
OF THE OF THE THEIR ABILITY TO
QUARANTINEWHEN THEY NEED TO L.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO LOSE
LIVES REAL LIVES. BECAUSE IT'S
INCONVENIENT FOR AN EMPLOYER
SO. I GET IT AND I DON'T WANT
TO ARGUE WITH YOU MISTER. FLOOR
I MEAN I UNDERSTAND. EMPLOY ARE
JUST NEED A LOT TO US. BUT ALL
I CAN SAY IS THIS JUST BECAUSE
YOU DON'T KNOW THESE INDIVIDUAL
WORKERS AND I'M ASKING YOU
PERSONALLY AND I KNOW YOU YOU
CARE I KNOW YOU CARE ABOUT
WORKERS BUT NOT. BUT WE IS A
STATE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ACCEPT.
DEATH AFTER DEATH AFTER DEATH
FUND IN THE WORKPLACE OF LATINO
PRIMARILY IMMIGRANT WORKERS
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW THEM.
THEY'RE NOT REAL TO US IN THIS
IS WHERE IT STOPS IN SOUTH. I
RESPECTFULLY. I AM. VOTING FOR
IT I HOPE EVERYBODY VOTES FOR
IT BUT EMPLOYERS ALSO HAVE TO
TAKE THE RESPONSIBILITY. AND IT
WILL NOT HURT YOU THANK YOU THE
RESULTS YET. THEY WILL NOT BE
IN ARE YOU BECAUSE WE HAVE A
GREAT REALLY BUT- I DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE LIKE MY FRUSTRATION
IS. WE AS THE STATE WE DO THIS
RIGHT BUT WE DON'T HOLD
OURSELVES. ACCOUNTABLE AS WELL.
LIKE WEEK WE THROW ALL THIS OUT
THERE WE THROW THE PLAN WE DO
ALL THESE THINGS. BUT WE ARE
NOT GIVING OUR BUSINESS TO BE
THE RESOURCES. TO DO THEIR JOBS
AS WELL. AND SO IT ALL DROPS
BACK ON THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
AND THEN WHEN THINGS IMPLODE OR
THINGS GO WRONG. THEY ARE
REALLY REALLY IN A TOUGH SPOT
AND SO YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
I MEAN I GREW UP WITH MIGRANT
WORKERS AT A HUGE PART OF MY
LIFE. AND WE HAVE TO FIGHT FOR
THEM ON A DAILY BASIS. MY
FRUSTRATION IS FAR MORE WITH
THE STATE THAN ANYTHING ELSE. I
AM SORRY I HOPE YOU'LL JOIN ME
WE ARE PUSHING THE GOVERNOR WE
GOT A COMMITMENT BECAUSE- THE-
HAPPY. WORKERS BILL THAT WE'RE
GOING TO VOTE ON TODAY ALSO
LEAVES OUT THE FACT THAT THESE
WORKERS ARE NOT BEING TESTED IN
AN- OUTBREAK CANNOT BE
DETERMINED WE ARE DEMANDING.
THAT THESE WORKERS GET TESTING
THAT THEY NEED FROM THE STATE
IN THE STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY I
HOPE YOU'LL FIND THAT LETTER
WITH LATINO CAUCUS. THAT THIS
IS NOT JUST THE EMPLOYER IT IS
ALSO THE STATE AND WE'VE GOT TO
DO THIS. BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
FIND OUT WHERE THE CONTACT IS
FROM. RIGHT THAT'S WHAT CONTACT
TRACING ALL ABOUT. I'M GLAD
THAT. WE'VE COME TO SOME
AGREEMENT THAT WE ALL CAN AGREE
ON ANYONE ELSE. FROM THE CAN
COMMITTEE. AND YOU KNOW I AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING I COLLEAGUES
SAID- AND ULTIMATELY THOSE ARE
AND WE HAVE TO DO BETTER AS A
STATE AND I THINK EVERYONE.
AGREES WITH THAT THAT BEING
SAID PROTECTING THESE WORKERS
THAT- IS ESSENTIAL FOR US TO DO
IS THE BARE MINIMUM IS A LEASE
THAT WE SHOULD DO IT AND DINNER
TO THE VICE YEARS POINT. HAVING
THIS DATA HAVING THIS
INFORMATION OUT QUICKLY WILL
ALLOW US TO RESPOND MUCH MORE
QUICKLY AND AS I'VE MENTIONED
BEFORE A BENCH ON THE FLOOR YOU
KNOW I'M AND I'M I LIVE IN
SOUTH OF THE CAPITAL SILICON
VALLEY IN THE BAY AREA. THE
CENSUS TRACTS OF THE MOST
DEATHS IN THE AREA OF MY
DISTRICT. THE SIZE SAN JOSE.
HOW THE LATINO THESE ARE THE
WORKERS. AND WHEN THEY ARE
DYING. AND NOT ONLY DOES PUBLIC
HELP DICTATE WE DO BETTER. BUT
WE OWE IT. TO THESE WORKERS TO
DO BETTER AND WE ABSOLUTELY
SHOULD DO MORE FIGURE OUT WHAT
WE CAN DO MORE AS A STATE. TO
PROVIDE THE TOOLS TO THE
BUSINESSES. TO PROTECT THE
WORKERS AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO DO WE'VE BEEN
PUTTING BILLS FOR. EVEN A BILL
MINOR WONDERFUL ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. GOT SLICED. DOWN TO A
FRACTION OF WHAT IT WAS.
ORIGINALLY WAS WHAT IT WAS WAS
THERE ARE DESIGNED TO PROTECT
WORKERS. SO I THINK I
APPRECIATED SOME AREAS WILL
BRING THIS. BILL FORWARD. THIS
IS A GOOD PUBLIC HEALTH BILL AS
MUCH AS IT IS ANYTHING ELSE.
AND ALLOWS US AND ALLOWS THE
WORKERS THERE RIGHT. TO NOW.
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE THE RAIN SO
WITH THAT- I DO HAVE A- HE-
THEN I RECOMMENDATION AND- WE
HAVE A MOTION. FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO SECOND
BY SUMMER GONZALEZ- SOME NUMBER
BRANDS WHICH I TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU I THINK. AT THIS BILL IS
ASKING THAT EVERY EMPLOYEE HAVE
THE RIGHT TO KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED. THERE'S
NOTHING ON THE BOOKS RIGHT NOW
THAT REQUIRES THAT NOTHING SO
THAT THAT NO EMPLOYER TELLS THE
EMPLOYEES THAT THEY'VE BEEN
EXPOSED THEY'RE NOT BREAKING
THE LAW. BECAUSE THEY'VE NOT
BEEN TOLD THAT THEY HAVE TO
NOTIFY THEM. THE SECOND THING
IS THAT IF THERE IS AN OUTBREAK
AND THAT IS THREE OR MORE THAN
THEY HAVE TO REPORT IT TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH. WE'RE NOT WE'RE
NOT SAYING THAT WITH THE ONE
ONE- POSITIVE CODED THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO START REPORTING
IF THERE IS AN OUTBREAK THREE
OR MORE IT NOW BECOMES OF THEY
HAVE TO REPORT. I DO WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE'VE MET TO
NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH. WITH
ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS THEIR OPPOSITION. THE
BILL HAS BEEN SUBSTANTIALLY
AMENDED TO SIMPLIFY NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS. DEFINE WHAT
TRIGGERS A NOTICE WE REMOVE
DUPLICATIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WE DEFINED AT THE
WORK SITE WERE REMOVED
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION WILL
REMOVE THE PENALTY WE EXEMPTED
MOST HEALTH CARE EMPLOYERS. AND
WE ADDED A TWO YEAR SUNSET. I'M
STILL COMMITTED TO WORK WITH
pSTAKEHOLDERS. BUT OUR WORKERS
CANNOT WAIT WE NEED TO PROTECT
THEM THEY HAVE AN ABSOLUTE
RIGHT TO KNOW WHEN THEY HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED SO THAT THEY CAN
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
LOVED ONES. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. WE WILL GO ON WITH. MOST
MOTION IS CONCUR WITH SENATE
AMENDMENTS KALRA KALRA HI FLORA
FLORA NO CARILLO CARILLO I DEEP.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER HI RIVAS
RIVAS I. SO WELL. DOES NOT HURT
THE SENTIMENTS. THANK YOU ALL.
WAIT TO GET YEAH. ALL OF ALARM.
FOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
SENATE LEADER THE SENTINEL THE
HAPLESS AND REPORT YOU KNOW HI
FI. SEVEN FIVE TWO NINE AND
GIVEN THE VERY. THANK YOU MISS
CHAIR MEMBERS TODAY I AM S. B.
C. TWENTY NINE ON BEHALF OF SAN
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO WHICH
WILL PROGRAM AN EMPLOYEE FROM
CIVIL PENALTIES FROM AN
EMPLOYER UNDER THE LABOR CODE-PRIVATE ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND FOUR FOR
VIOLATIONS OF PROVISIONS
REQUIRING THE EMPLOYER TO
PROVIDE MEAL AND REST BREAKS IF
THE EMPLOYEE ENGAGED IN REMOTE
WORK AS SPECIFIED. IN THE MIDST
OF THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
MANY EMPLOYERS HAVE INSTITUTED
WORK FROM HOME OPTIONS FOR
THEIR EMPLOYEES FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES AN EFFORT TO RETAIN
THE WORK FORCE AND MAINTAIN
WORKERS LIVELIHOODS WHILE MANY
BUSINESSES AND NISHIDA
TELEWORKING FLEXIBILITY TO
COMPLY WITH STATE AND LOCAL
STATE HOME ORDERS TELEWORKING
REMAINS CRITICAL FOR BOTH
EMPLOYERS AND WORKERS AS THE
STATE RE OPENS PROVIDING
WORKERS WITH THE ABILITY TO
WORK REMOTELY FROM HOME IS ONE
OF THE ONLY VIABLE OPTIONS FOR
MANY BUSINESSES TO CONTINUE
THEIR OPERATIONS AND FOR
WORKERS TO STAY IN THEIR JOBS.
HOWEVER EMPLOYERS HAVE
EXPRESSED GROWING CONCERNS THAT
THEY ARE UNABLE TO MONITOR
WHETHER THEY'RE TELEWORKING
EMPLOYEES ARE TAKING MEAL A
MEAL AND REST BREAKS AS
REQUIRED UNDER THE LABOR CODE
BUSINESS GROUPS HAVE NOTED THAT
THEY ARE INCREASINGLY WORRIED
THAT TEMPORARY WELL INTENTIONED
SOLUTIONS SUCH AS TELEWORKING
TO KEEP PEOPLE WORKING WILL NOT
BE SUSTAINABLE IN THE WEEKS AND
MONTHS AHEAD DUE TO THE RISK OF
POTENTIAL PAGA SUITS FOR
ALLEGED FAILURES TO PROVIDE
MEAL AND REST BREAKS TO THEIR
TELEWORKING EMPLOYEES. TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THIS BILL
TEMPORARILY SUSPENDS CERTAIN
PAGA SUITS IF THE FOLLOWING
THREE CONDITIONS ARE MET NUMBER
ONE THE EMPLOYEE BEGAN TO WORK
FROM THE EMPLOYEES HOME.
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AFTER MARCH
NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY AT THE
EMPLOYERS DIRECTION UNDER AN
EMPLOYER POLICY PERMITTING SUCH
REMOTE WORK OR PURSUANT TO AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE EMPLOYER.
NUMBER TWO THE ALLEGED
VIOLATIONS OCCURRED IN THE
PERIOD BETWEEN BEGINNING WITH
MARCH NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
AND NDING DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND
ARE FOR MEAL AND REST BREAKS
THE EMPLOYER FAILED TO PROVIDE
TO AN EMPLOYEE WHILE THAT
EMPLOYEE WAS WORKING FOR THE
EMPLOYER FROM HOME OR OTHER
PLACE OF RESIDENCE. AND THE
NUMBER THREE THE AGGRIEVED
EMPLOYEE DOES NOT RESIDE ON
PROPERTY OWNED BY THE EMPLOYER
OR PROVIDED BY THE EMPLOYER TO
THE EMPLOYEE. WE SHOULD BE
DOING OUR BEST TO ENCOURAGE ALL
BUSINESSES THAT CAN WORK
REMOTELY TO DO SO FOR THE
DURATION OF THE PANDEMIC.
PROVIDING WORKERS WITH THE
ABILITY TO WORK REMOTELY FROM
HOME IS ONE OF THE ONLY VIA A
VIABLE OPTIONS FOR MANY
BUSINESSES TO CONTINUE THEIR
OPERATIONS AND FOR WORKERS TO
STAY IN THEIR JOBS. I DO HAVE
TWO WITNESSES ON THE PHONE WHO
CAN HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS AND-
MR CHAU ALLOWED THEM TO. SELF
INTRODUCE VISUAL SURE AS YOU
COLUMN SURE YES- THANK YOU- THE
SUMMER GRAYSON AND- JUST OF ALL
OUR BILLS THIS EVENING- YOU
SETTLE HAVE UP TO FOUR MINUTES
AND SO WITH THE- TWO WITNESSES
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE BEEN
ADEQUATE COVERAGE OF THE
COMMERCE OF THE FOR JUST THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION.
SPLIT UP ANYTIME YOU WANT- WILL
START AS SOON AS A BENNIGAN'S
ALL START THE- FOUR MINUTES SO
THEN IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE- IF
WE CAN. GET MISTER HAVE BEEN
GONE. GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER YOU VERY THAT THAT
HAVING BACK TO THE- CHAMBER
FROM IN SUPPORT OF THAT BEING
SEVEN TWO NINE. OF ALL WE JUST
WANT EXPRESS OUR BRIDGE TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND FOR INCLUDING
THIS ITEM AND ITS ECONOMIC
PACKAGE FOR THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. ENTERPRISE ARE
APPRECIATION THE SENATOR
PORTANTINO FOR CARRYING THIS
MEASURE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON FOR- PRESENTING IT
TONIGHT. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
POGBA IS SOMEWHAT OF A THIRD
RAIL. ISSUE WITH VERY STRONG
FEELINGS ON BOTH SIDES. BUT IN
OUR OPINION THIS BILL PROVIDES
VERY MODEST AND COMMONSENSE
RELIEF THAT WILL ASSIST
EMPLOYERS. IN OFFERING CAL WORK
AS AN OPTION DURING THIS
CRISIS. UNDER THIS BILL
EMPLOYERS WILL STILL HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE MEAL AND
REST PERIODS YOU'LL PLEASE
WORKING FROM HOME UNDER THE
SAME STANDARDS THAT EXIST UNDER
EXISTING LAW. TELL YOU. TELL
YOU TO PROVIDE ME YOUR RECORDS
WILL STILL ENTITLE EMPLOYEES TO
RECOVER THE OUR PREMIUM PAY.
UNDER LABOR CODE SECTION TWO TO
SIX POINT SEVEN FOR EACH MISSED
BREAK. ALL THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE IS THAT THERE IS NO
RECOVERY OF ADDITIONAL PAGA
PENALTIES ON TOP OF THAT FOR
SUCH VIOLATIONS. WORKING FROM
HOME. FOR A LIMITED PERIOD OF
TIME DURING THIS CRISIS UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE THINK
THIS IS A NEEDED STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND WILL
PROVIDE SOME MODEST LITIGATION
RELIEF TO EMPLOYERS TRYING TO
DO THE RIGHT THING DURING THIS
CRISIS. BY ALLOWING EMPLOYEES
TO WORK FROM HOME. ESPECIALLY
WITH TE ONGOING NATURE OF THE
PANDEMIC AND THE CONTINUED
CLOSURE OF SCHOOLS. WE NEED TO
BE ENCOURAGING EMPLOYERS OFFER
TELL WORKING AS AN OPTION WHERE
POSSIBLE. IT IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO AVOID THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS AND MANY EMPLOYEES
PREFER AND NEED THIS OPTION AT
THE TIME. REDUCING THE PRODUCT
POCKET LITIGATION READ. IN THIS
NARROW SITUATION. WILL REMOVE
AN OBSTACLE TO EMPLOYERS
OFFERING THE TELEWORK AS AN
OPTION. WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU TO VIEW THIS PROPOSAL
IN LIGHT OF THE MANY NEW
OBLIGATIONS BEING PLACED ON
BUSINESSES DURING THE PANDEMIC
IN ADDITION TO THE UNDERLYING
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THE CRISIS
ITSELF. IT WOULD BE APPRECIATED
LEGISLATURE COULD PROVIDE AT
LEAST SOME MODEST RELIEF TO
EMPLOYERS IN THIS REGARD AND
AGAIN WE THINK IT WILL ENABLE
THEM TO OFFER TELEWORKING AS AN
OPTION TO THE BENEFIT OF BOTH
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES AT WORK
WORKERS. FOR THESE REASONS WE
SUPPORT SB SEVEN TWENTY NINE
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR I. THE
IMMATURE CARE I'D ALSO LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT I'M HAPPY THAT
SEPARATE CLIENTS THE NATIONAL
PAYROLL REPORTING CONSORTIUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER IRVING- FIFTH BARGES
WITH THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION. EVEN MEDICARE
NUMBER EIGHT FORGET ON BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT AT. SEVEN TWENTY
NINE. WOULD LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE GOVERNOR AND THE
AUTHOR FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS COMMONSENSE PAGA REFORMS.
OUR MEMBERS ARE LEADERS AND
MANY OF THE OBJECT THAT HELD BY
THE COMMITTEE. AND THAT MORE
AND THEIR EMPLOYEE TRAINING AND
BENEFITS. THEY'RE MORE LIKELY
TO PROMOTE WENT INTO EXECUTIVE
MANAGEMENT THEY HAVE BETTER
RECORDS ON ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP. AND ARE LESS
LIKELY TO LAY OFF WORKERS IN
TOUGH ECONOMIC TIMES LIKE THE
PRESENT. FAMILY BUSINESSES TAKE
TO HEART THE RESPONSIBILITY
THAT THEY HAVE TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES. ONE EIGHT. SEVEN
FOUR EIGHT. DESPITE THE
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES
BECAUSE THEY NINETEEN
CALIFORNIANS PLAYERS ARE MAKING
EVERY EFFORT TO HONOR THOSE
RESPONSIBILITIES. AT GREAT RISK
AND EXPENSE MANY CALIFORNIANS
PLAYERS THAT THAT THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL UNASSIGNED TO
PROVIDE ARRANGEMENTS FOR
EMPLOYEES TO WORK FROM HOME. SB
EVEN TWENTY NINE GET BOTH
EMPLOYERS ACTED IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF OUR EMPLOYEES
SAFETY. AT THE MALL REPRIEVE
FROM THE THREAT AT THE FOR THE
DEFENSE WHICH WOULD SHATTER
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
THIRD THE COMMUNITY
GENERATIONS. AND JEOPARDIZE THE
JOBS THATTHE MEN AND WOMEN AND
THEIR FAMILIES. BUT WE NEED
THEM. I BELIEVE THE- MARKET
SUPPORT AT SEVEN TWENTY NINE
AND A HALF. YOU'RE EITHER AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW TO PUBLIC
AND- WE ASK YOU JUST A YOUR
NAME A- OF HIS. ON THE BILL
PLEASE AND I'M GONNA START WAS.
RIGHT NOW BEFORE WE GET. TO
TALK TO SOME ELSE'S. ANYONE IN
THE ROOM AND- RIGHT NEXT TO BE
DRUM OR DO WE HAVE ANY IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. YES AND
AS A REMINDER TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE WILL
START WITH ONE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY FOUR YOU
ARE ALL BUT. YES GOOD EVENING I
ACTUALLY I'M IN CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION I BOTTOM A WE ARE
NOT POSITION ABOUT THE SEVEN
TWENTY NINE I JUST GOT IN THE
WRONG QUEUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF LOCAL MY POSITION THANK YOU
WON'T KNOW THAT SIT ON THE CALL
BACK AND APPRECIATE THAT
ANYONE- IF YOU MISTER MODERATOR
FOR GO TO. SUPPORT OKAY AGAIN
LATER JUMP CHAU YOUR SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME IT'S ONE FILED BY
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO ONE
EIGHTY ONE. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KEVIN
PEDRETTI REPRESENTING NFIB WE
ARE SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DILLON GIBBONS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE EIGHTY TWO. YOU TOO YOU
ARE OPEN. IT WILL MOVE TO OUR
LIVES SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING AT MEDICARE
MEMBERS OF THE TURKEY HUGHES OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF FOOD
PRODUCERS AND THE PART OF THE
MAJOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
THIRTY YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO
PUBLIC YES. SORRY THIS IS THE
RIGHT LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIVE FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE LARA AND PAYCHECK
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA GRAVERT
AND CALVIN GRESCHNER THE
SITUATION IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. URSULA CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION AND SPORT.
THANK YOU. WINDS SEVENTY NOT
ASKING THE RIGHT SEVENTY NINE
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS A
COMMITTEE THIS IS CHRIS WALKER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SHEET METAL AND
AIR CONDITIONING CONTRACTORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. THANK
YOU. IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP OKAY. MOMENT PLEASE.
I WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT.
THEY'RE SO WITH THE OPERATE
OKAY I GUESS THAT PERSON WAS IN
OPPOSITION SO THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS THAT QUEUING
UP IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL OKAY
OPPOSITION AND TO TEST THE
OPPOSITE BY. A COLLECT. YOU
HAVE UP TO FOUR MINUTES- WE
HAVE SEVERAL FLOCKS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
FALL BY THE RECALL YOSHIHARA
WITH CALIFORNIAN PLANET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION MISS FOX. MEDICARE
MEMBERS TERAFLOPS CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SEVEN TWENTY NINE. AND
WERE IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE THIS
BILL TAKES AWAY THE ONLY
ENFORCEMENT TOOL AVAILABLE TO
MOST CALIFORNIA WORKERS AND
THEREFORE SIGNIFICANTLY WEEKEND
THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO MEAL
AND REST BREAKS FOR EMPLOYEES
DOING TELEWORK. AND WHEN WE
THINK OF TELEWORK WE OFTEN
THINK OF A WHITE COLLAR
PROFESSIONAL ON A LAPTOP. THAT
HAS THE ABILITY TO CONTROL
THEIR OWN SCHEDULE AND TAKE A
BREAK WHEN THEY WANT. HOWEVER
THIS BILL DOES NOT JUST APPLY
TO WELL COMPENSATED
PROFESSIONALS WORKING AT HOME
THIS BILL APPLIES TO ALL
WORKERS WORKING REMOTELY
WHATEVER THEIR JOB. AND
WHATEVER CONTROL THEIR EMPLOYER
HAS OVER THAT. MANY LOW WAGE
INDUSTRIES HAVE SHIFTED TO
TELEWORK AND HOME BASED WORK
INCLUDING CALL CENTERS
PACKAGING AND DISTRIBUTION
TRANSCRIPTION TRANSLATION
TUTORING PRIVATE SCHOOL
TEACHING DATA ENTRY SOCIAL
MEDIA MODERATORS AND MANY
OTHERS. ONE OF THE ORIGINAL
WORK FROM HOME INDUSTRIES WITH
THE GARMENT INDUSTRY. USES IN
THE GARMENT INDUSTRY IS WHY
HOME BASED GARMENT WORK IS NOW
PROHIBITED. JUST BECAUSE THE
JOB IS DONE AT HOME DOES NOT
MEAN THAT BASICALLY FOR
PROTECTIONS ARE NECESSARY. IN
GARMENT EMPLOYERS EXERTED
CONTROL OVER WORKERS SUPPORT
QUOTAS AND PIECE RATE TODAY
TECHNOLOGY HAS MADE IT EVEN
EASIER FOR EMPLOYERS TO MONITOR
SURVEIL AND CONTROL EVERY
MINUTE OF WORKERS TIME. THIS
pSHOULD HAVE STRENGTHENED LABOR
LAWS NOT THE ELIMINATION OF THE-
THIS BILL WOULD TAKE AWAY THE
ONLY ENFORCEMENT TOOL AVAILABLE
TO MOST WORKERS MORE THAN 60%
OF CALIFORNIA WORKERS ARE
FORCED TO SIGN ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS UPON HIGHER. CIVIL
PENALTIES SO PAGA PENALTIES ARE
THE ONLY FORM OF ENFORCEMENT
THAT COURTS HAVE FOUND CANNOT
BE RESTRICTED BY ARBITRATION.
BY TAKING AWAY PAGA PENALTIES
THIS BILL ELIMINATES ANY
ENFORCEMENT OR DUE PROCESS FOR
MANY WORKERS SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY WORK AT HOME. THERE'S ALSO
KNOWS AND OF THE NEED TO
ELIMINATE PROTECTION. WE ALWAYS
HAD PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING AT HOME AND TELEWORKING
WE'VE NOT SEEN A CRISIS OF PAGA
CLAIMS THE PANDEMIC HAS NOT.
SHOWN THAT DAY BEARD THE COURTS
ARE CLOGGED WITH POCKET CLAIMS.
TO THE EVIDENCE FOR THIS HUGE
SHIFT IS JUST NOT THERE AND
LASTLY ELIMINATING THE RIGHTS
THAT WORKERS FOUGHT AND DIED
FOR DECADES AGO SHOULD NOT BE
RUSHED THROUGH AT THE END OF
SESSION WITHOUT ADEQUATE
VETTING FOR CONSIDERATION OF
THE CONSEQUENCES. FOR MILLIONS
OF WORKERS WHO ARE WORKING AT
HOME. AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
URGE A NO VOTE ON SB SEVEN
TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU. OF THE
SURCHARGE COULD YOU ABOUT A
MINUTE AND FIFTEEN SECONDS. THE
FOUR MINUTE MINUTE. OKAY I WILL
GO FAST THANK YOUR CHAIRMAN
BIRDS. ARE WHAT HE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
IT DOESN'T TAKE THE TIME TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS
MADE AND THE PORT OF THE BILL.
IT WAS STATED THAT THE THREE
MANY OF THEM THE REASON FOR THE
BILL THE NEED FOR THE BILL IS
THAT EMPLOYERS HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERN THAT. THEY CAN'T
MONITOR THEIR WORKERS WHO ARE
REMOTE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE TAKING MAIL AROUND. IT
THEN I DON'T WANT TO ACTUALLY
QUOTE FROM THE DRINKER-
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
DECISION WHICH ACTUALLY SAYS
THAT THE EMPLOYER IS NOT
OBLIGATED TO POLICE NO BREAK
AND ENSURE NO WORK THERE AFTER
IT'S PERFORMED. BONA FIDE
RELEASED FROM DUTY AND THE
RELINQUISHING OF CONTROL
SATISFIED THE EMPLOYERS
ALTHOUGH. AND WORK BY A
RELIEVED IN PLAY DURING THE
MEAL BREAK NOT THEREBY PLAYED
THE EMPLOYER IN VIOLATION OF
THE OBLIGATION AND CREATE
LIABILITY- BE PROPONENTS ALSO
SET SAID THAT THE LAW DOES NOT
CHANGED- THE DUTY TO PROVIDE A
MEAL OR REST BREAKS AND THAT
THERE WOULD STILL BE A
LIABILITY UNDER THE LABOR CODE
BUT- AS- I WILL JUST MENTION.
ON BECAUSE MOST OF THESE
WORKERS HAVE SIGN FORCED
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS IT
REALLY DOESN'T MATTER BECAUSE A
WORKER WOULD BE ABLE TO FILE A
CLAIM ANYWAY AND THEIR ONLY
OPTION TO ENFORCE THE RIGHT FOR
MILLER REST BREAK WOULD BE
THROUGH. THAT AND I THINK THAT
THE BILL DOES THE FILM THAT
EMPLOYEES TO WORK REMOTELY HAVE
THE FREEDOM AND FLEXIBILITY TO
TAKE A BREAK WHEN THEY WANT. OF
COURSE ANY MILLERITES BREAK
CLAIM WOULD HAVE. TO BE
FRIVOLOUS OR MARYLAND MARYLAND.
BUT EVEN THE VERY DANGER THAT
SOME BECAUSE THERE'S A- BEEN A-
SHARP RIGHT IN THE- OF BEEN.
AND THE TYPE CONTROL GRID
EMPLOY EARTH. OVER THE WORKERS
AT THE TO DO TO THE NEW BOOK
REMOTE WORKING CAN. THERE'S
EVEN GREATER. EMPOWER COULD. ON
WORKERS. BECAUSE ARE AMONG. AND
I'LL JUST MENTION THAT THERE
WAS A RETHINK IF YOU IF YOU
COULD IF YOU COULD ARRIVE UP
THE MASSAGER. SHARE 26% OF HR
LEADERS HAVE USED USED SOME
FORM OF STOP OR TO TRACK REMOTE
WORKER SO THERE IS DEFINITELY A
LOT OF CONTROL OVER WORKERS
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE IN THEIR
HOMES AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WORKERS STILL HAVE
THE RIGHT TO TAKE A MEAL OR
REST BREAKS IN THE UP STRONGLY
URGE YOUR NOTEBOOK THANK YOU.
THANK THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ANYONE IN
THE ROOM IF NOT ABOUT THIS
PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN FOR THOSE
IN OPPOSITION JUST JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE-
MONNESS MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE. YES WE DO
HAVE A NUMBER OF PARTICIPANTS
AND TO SHOW THEIR OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND FIRST WE WOULD LIKE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
NUMBERS KEVIN DE TO PUT MORE
CONSERVATIVES UNION OF
CALIFORNIA AND OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. BY EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CARE MIKE
CARROLL WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. IT FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE TERM
MEMBERS THAT'S THAT NOT HAVE
LEGAL RIGHTS ADVOCATE AND
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
RIGHT SIXTY YOU ARE OPEN WHAT
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRISTY
VALVE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S NOT
BERNIE SANDERS ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS OF THE GRANT WHILE IT A
SINGLE LAST STATES AND DROP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY
YOUR OPEN. AT FIRST WHICH OF
THE CALL THE SUPREME IN THE
DEADLINE AND- THANK YOU. RIGHT
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK MATTHEW THE CARLOS OF
THAT SETTING LEGAL SERVICE IN
OUR- THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE COMMISSION
GOT SPENT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION UNITE HERE
MACHINISTS UNION. INTERNATIONAL
FEDERATION OF PROFESSIONAL AND
TECHNICAL ENGINEERS THE
ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS OF
CALIFORNIA UNITED. UTILITY
WORKERS UNION OF AMERICA AND
THE INLAND BOATMEN UNION ALL
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. WE WILL GO
TO LINE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CLOTURE MEMBERS THAT METAL JAM
BAPHOMET YEAH YOU A POST. THANK
YOU. BY FIFTY THREE YOU ARE
OPEN. WHERE ON THE TOP OF THE
TABLE AGRICULTURE EDUCATION
FRIENDLY AND CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TAYLOR JACKSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION OR LONGER ONLY A
STRONG AND OUR ABILITY TO
ENFORCE THEM OR HERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. FIVE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS LOCAL THANK YOU. BY
FORTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
CATEGORY ON BEHALF OF LEGAL AID
AT WORK ON BOTH PHONES. THANK
YOU BUT MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. I'M DOORS
A MOTION BUT NO SECOND IS OR
ANY COMMENTS. WE'RE THE SECONDS.
WE DO NOT TO THERE'S A MOTION
ON THE TABLE. THE SECOND OR
SECOND. A FOR EFFORT MR FLORIDA
A PRESS REFERENCE OF A FOR
EFFORT MISTER VICE CHAIR OR TO
GO BACK I CAN THINK I WOULD
EXPECT NOTHING LESS. IS MOTION.
SO IF SHARE THERE WAS NO VOTE
TAKEN IS IT STILL POSSIBLE TO
ASK FOR RECONSIDERATION.
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO VOTE TAKEN
SO I'M NOT SURE IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE. WITHOUT WHO WAS A
REPUBLICAN MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE. THERE'S A MOTION ON
THE TABLE. OKAY THANK YOU YEAH.
OKAY YEAH. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER GRAYSON THANK YOU
TEMPERATURE AND MEMBERS. THE
DEAL THANK ENERGIZED HER. MR
FLOOR YEAH. ALL RIGHT WELL YOU
OF. ALL RIGHTS RESERVED TIME
NUMBER CARILLO. ALSO BECAUSE
ONE ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. THE BIPARTISAN.
YEAH. SO. IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR
CAN I FIT HERE TO STOKE ANY
ADDITIONAL CONTACT THANK YOU
PERFECTLY I AM A THAT
PRESENTING AB FIFTEEN TWELVE
WHICH WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY TO THE SECURITY
INDUSTRY AND ENSURE WE CAN
BETTER PROTECT OUR WORKERS AND
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY BY PROVIDING
GUIDANCE TO EMPLOYERS I'LL KEEP
THIS SHORT SINCE WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN MOTION
HAS BEEN MADE ON THE PHONE FOR.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IS
KELLY JOHNSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSE SECURITY AGENCIES
GARDEN THE SOVIETS AND RENEE
BAYARDO WITH A SAY YOU
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU YOU HAVE
UP TO FOUR MINUTES MISS TO TAKE
UP THE WHOLE TIME SO GO AHEAD
WITH THE WITNESSES PLEASE. YES
I CAN'T REMEMBER KELLY JENSEN
REPRESENTING HELP BARCA WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IT'S A GREAT LABOR MANAGEMENT-
BILLABLE TO CLARIFY THE LAW
RELATED REST BREAKS AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION WE ASK FOR
NOT ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE TERM MEMBERS ON A
BY OUR TO LOOK AT YOU KNOW YOU
CALIFORNIA I WOULD JUST SAY
BRIEFLY THAT OUR MEMBERS TO SEE
THEMSELVES VIRTUOUS BONTA
COMBAT IF AN EMERGENCY HAPPENED
AT A PROPERTY THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO HELP PEOPLE THAT'S WHY
THEY SUPPORT THE BILL WE ASK
FOR SUPPORT. THANKS THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ONE ALSO SUPPORT. I
AM ON THE PHONE MILLIONS VOTER.
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO ONE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS ACTUALLY HOW OFTEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN TWELVE. THANK YOU.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP IN
SUPPORT OF THIS TIME. MISTER
CALDERON OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME OKAY WE HAVE WE HAVE NO
ONE LISTED IN OPPOSITION BUT I
HAVE TO ASK BUT IT WAS IN
OPPOSITION. SO MISS MODERATORS
OR ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. SHOW
YOUR OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WHAT IS CUTER QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR. OKAY.
NO ONE'S COMING UP IS THAT
CORRECT. YES THAT IS CORRECT
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. ANY OTHER
FURTHER ANY FURTHER COMMENTS
AREN'T REAL VERY SPIRITED
DEBATE TODAY SO IT THANK I
GUESS IT'S A REALLY GREAT WAY
TO END THE WITHOUT EVER AND THE
CHAMBER COMING TOGETHER TO PASS
WORKERS THANKS I WOULD. THANKS
TO THE ROTARY OF PHILIP TO VOTE
ON IT MADAMS CONSULT. YOU CAN
FOLLOW PLEASE. MOTION IS CONCUR
WITH AMENDMENTS KALRA I KALRA I
FLORA. LARA I CARILLO I CARILLO
I DEEP GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER TRY
RIVAS. RIVAS I BILLS OUT. THE
BILLS OUT AND I WANT TO THANK
OTHERS CHIEF CONSULTANT GOING
FOR A GREAT YEAR AS WELL AS-
THE VESSEL LABOR STAFF THAT IS
NOT WITH US BUT OUR COMMITTEE
SECTOR LAURIE OVER AS A
PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT JUSTIN
DELIVERIES AND ALL THE MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF REPUBLICAN
CONSULTANT THANK YOU PUBLIC
AND- AND- I'LL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR FIVE FOR FIVE MINUTES
OR UNTIL I HEAR OTHERWISE FROM
MISTER DEEP. LOOK AT A LETTER
FROM. THE BILL HAS YEAH I HAVE
I HAVE REMEMBER THIS. ONE THING
ABOUT I HAVE MET EVER ABOUT.
OKAY NO PROBLEM THE. WHAT IS.
YEAH. FINALLY OPEN. YEAH YOU
KNOW. THE FOR THE MONTH. YEAH I
WANT TO TALK.
YEAH RIGHT YEAH.
ACTUALLY I WAS ON MY. I DON'T I
DON'T. ONE EIGHTY SIXTY FIVE
SUMMARY IS RECOMMENDED DO DO
PASS AND WE IF WE CAN. A
CERTAIN EMOTION IS TO CONCUR
WITH SENATE AMENDMENTS- IF WE
CAN PULL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
YOU'RE GOING BEFORE. WELL SO I
GOT AHEAD. D. NO JEEP NO ALL
RIGHT AND THEN FILE ITEM THREE
I'M SORRY FILE ITEM TO AB
FIFTEEN TWELVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AND THAT'S ALSO A
MOTION TO CONCUR ASSIGNMENTS
MOTIONS TO CONCUR WITH SENATE
AMENDMENTS DEEP. BY DEEP HI.
AND THEN THAT'S THOSE ARE THE
ONLY TWO MOTIONS OF ABOUT FOR
US TONIGHT. WE ARE ADJOURNED.